quand j'étais gosse on apprenait aux
gars comme moi à respecter les codes et
aux blancs
qu'est ce que tu as dit
antonio soprano
est ce qu'il serait possible de vous
parler cela seul un moment madame
soprano
selon l'échelle standford binet il a un
qi élevé
vous aurez beaucoup de mal à me
convaincre il a 6 de moyenne générale
ça c'est parce qu'ils ne s'appliquent
pas mais il est intelligent
les résultats sont éloquents c'est un
meneur
et on claudique
rendirent dans la famille
ça poursuit toujours mais
[Musique]
tu es mon neveu
je suis prêt à faire tout ce que je
pourrai pour t'aider
de les offres
je veux aller à l'université
ce serait con d'être chauffé avec ça
écoute tu emportes les enceintes et en
même temps tu dis je puiserai plus
jamais quoi que ce soit de ma vie c'est
tout simple
laisse-moi lui parler il n'écoute que
vicky
il faut que je m'occupe de tiki maltais
santé
peut-être que certaines choses que tu
fais
ne blesse pas dieu
hahaha
je lui montre l'exemple
il prendra la bonne décision il en a
dans le ventre ce gosse
pour ce qui est de ton neveu
naïve asie évite d'être mêlé de sa vie
[Musique]